there's a woman who at an Iowa Town Hall
confronted anti Obamacare Republican
Senator Chuck Grassley over the weekend
and the video of the confrontation has
gone viral and I'm gonna play it for you
in a moment but to set it up one of the
saddest things about conservative strict
father morality in the United States is
the complete and total lack of empathy
that pervades right-wing elected
officials who sort of subscribe to that
political philosophy or ideology and
there are all these stories we've heard
over the years of a homophobic anti-gay
Republican who learned their child's gay
and suddenly they have a change of heart
they're no longer as anti gay they're no
longer as opposed to gay adoption or gay
marriage or whatever and I've explained
before okay it's good that these
right-wing homophobes suddenly saw LGBT
rights differently once it affected them
personally and they came over to the
right position but why does it need to
affect them personally before they can
actually empathize with other people who
are in a particular situation every
single time that a conservative
homophobe sees the light on gay rights
okay it's good but can't we as the
thinking species as Homo sapiens can't
we use abstract thinking to imagine what
it would be like to have a gay or
lesbian child and see that the law is
stacked against them and see that there
is discrimination implicit in our
society even if we don't actually have a
gay child and we've seen similar
confrontations happen to what I'm about
to show you along here'll health care
lines before we're a sick person we'll
confront the lawmaker who wants to pass
a law that will lead to tons of people
losing their health care and some
portion of those people losing their
lives in Iowa over the weekend it was
Robin stone Robin stone has a
pre-existing condition she confronted
Chuck Grassley about how what he wants
to do with health care what he's voted
to do multiple times with the affordable
care act act puts her life at risk and
it escalated very quickly and I
understand why Robin stone got mad in
the
video grassley played this game where he
pretends that the threat to the
Affordable Care Act is that it might be
declared unconstitutional but Robin
stone reminds him well aside from the
constitutionality you voted to repeal
Obamacare multiple times and he gets all
blubber mouth than tries to make excuses
and then he actually if you're watching
you'll see him lean over and start to
berate this woman as if she's the stupid
one even though it's his position and
his party's position that is
unconscionable here that's your question
so the Affordable Care Act is the law of
the land
sacré be repealed become do you think
there's going to be repealed
the last time we voted for Neil was when
McCain folded the other way if there's
no cancer repeal of the now decided
simply passing this I live in three
united states house where the ten things
so what he can so what are you worried
about chuck Grassley is calming her down
by saying don't worry you'll get
treatment for your pre-existing
condition and you'll get your
medications because we have Obamacare
and she's saying that's what I'm
confronting you about you want to get
rid of Obamacare that's exactly why I'm
here asking you this question and he
insists well Obamacare is the law what
are you so worried about she's worried
about you chuck because you and your
cronies have voted to get rid of it
multiple times in the house it was what
60 votes in the Senate many votes she
says seven I don't know the exact number
and meanwhile and this is I mean let
this thing sink in for a moment the
sickness of this her taxes pay for chuck
Grassley health insurance right if chuck
Grassley had an ounce of moral rectitude
in his body he would say you know what
Robin I empathize with you
that sounds really stressful I can't
even imagine dealing with your illness
while also being worried about losing
your care I don't want you to lose your
care
here's why I think you will be better
off with an alternative to Obamacare
like I disagree with that assertion
unless you're saying single-payer of
some kind but at least then we can have
the real debate which is which system
works best dis chuck Grassley actually
have a viable alternative to Obamacare
that's not Grassley's actual situation
he doesn't actually have a good
alternative to Obamacare but at least it
be an honest debate instead he's playing
these games well listen we have the
Affordable Care Act and I don't think
it's going to be found unconstitutional
so don't worry about it which excuses
him from having to actively throw the
Affordable Care Act in the trash or at
least try to every time the Senate takes
a vote on it truly a disgusting human
being chuck Grassley who should be
voted out immediately and
congratulations to Robin stone because
in those situations um it can be very
easy you know you think of your question
and you go in and you're ready and then
all of a sudden it's the middle of the
townhall and you get a chance to ask it
and she you know she like many others do
a good job of getting the question out
but then they immediately get sort of
hypnotized by the way that senators and
many lawmakers are able to sort of
defuse or distract or misdirect with
talking points like I don't think you
have to worry it's not going to be found
unconstitutional she didn't take her eye
off the ball which is forget about what
the Supreme Court decides if ever it
does about the constitutionality you
actively voted multiple times to remove
this from part of our healthcare
infrastructure which would potentially
kill me and she did a really great job
of not sort of losing the thread there
Grassley's gotta be voted out they've
all got to be voted out make sure you're
following the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show and while
you're there follow me at David Pakman
quick break back after this if you love
learning new things you probably want to
check this out
the david pakman show today is sponsored
by Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolor painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career
rear by learning new skills that will
help you at your job I've gotten a ton
out of it Pat has taken some courses
that he's found really valuable and I
think you'll love it to get started for
free by clicking the link under this
video